on a beaucoup parlé de la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre en médecine humaine mais
les vétérinaires pour animaux de ferme
se font aussi très rares les besoins
sont particulièrement criants dans des
régions comme l’abbitivité misscamingue
l'outaway les Laurentides une de nos
équipes a d'ailleurs suivi pendant
quelques jours la seule vétérinaire du
secteur de Mont-Laurier dans les
Laurentides une professionnelle
passionnée mais à bout de souffle
[Musique]
use
Valérie Harrison en voie de toutes les
couleurs au cours d'une journée de
travail
c'est la seule vétérinaire dans la
région de Mont-Laurier son territoire
couvre 12000 km
. elle soigne des troupeaux de vaches
laitières de chèvres de moutons des
cervidés des bovins de boucheries des
poules basse-cour et des alpagas
[Musique]
à -25
aussi se tenir en forme bon travail dans
toutes les conditions possibles
inimaginables
c'est pas tout le monde qui veut faire
du multi espèce il y en a qui aiment
vraiment la routine donc tout le temps
la même chose ça ils sont plus
confortables avec ça je crois que ça
c'est une des raisons le nombre de gares
aussi
c'est juste
[Applaudissements]
à peu près à quelle heure tu commences
mais des fois même pas mais si jamais à
quelle heure tu finis donc il y a
certaines personnes qui veulent pas ils
veulent pas s'installer en région à
cause de ça est-ce que il y a un plaisir
ou un avantage à ça
comme moi je trouve fun dans ma pratique
c'est j'aime pas la routine fait que
j'aime bien ça toucher un peu à tout
[Musique]
dans la région les principaux clients
des vétérinaires les producteurs
laitiers sont peu nombreux
il faut faire beaucoup de route pour
aller à leur rencontre un irritant de
plus qui a fini par saper le moral des
deux vétérinaires qui travaillaient avec
Valérie Harrison
il y a un vétérinaire qui est parti pour
une autre région puis il y en a une
autre qui était la pratique donc à
partir de juillet
je suis tout seul comment ça s'est passé
pour vous
[Musique]
c'est toutes les questions tu te remets
en question est-ce que je continue
j'arrête je m'en vais ailleurs change de
métier c'est parce que tout seul ça se
fait pas ça se fait juste pour être tout
seul 24h/24 c'est jour sur 7 le teas pas
de vie tu as pas été j'ai une famille
j'ai des enfants j'ai je vais avoir des
loisirs aussi
j'adore mon métier j'adore ce que je
fais mais
faut qu'il y a autre chose aussi
[Musique]
depuis que ces partenaires ont quitté la
région Valérie Harrison a dû fermer sa
clinique de Mont Laurier sa maison est
envahie par son matériel vétérinaire
elle y a même aménagé un laboratoire
elle travaille maintenant comme sous
contractante pour une clinique basée
dans la naudière à 3 heures de route de
chez elle
[Musique]
ça l'oblige à avoir une partie de sa
pharmacie à portée de main
on a appelé ma pâte qu'on essayait
d'avoir du financement pour avoir des
vétérinaires
24/7 ici tu mettes vétérinaire qui monte
pendant deux semaines puis après ça
c'est un autre vétérinaire qui monte
pendant deux semaines qu'on avait des
subventions pour ça sauf que il y a pas
eu de main levée
[Musique]
moi je pense que c'est un service
essentiel si on veut maintenant un
territoire agricole qui viable et qui
qui a une raison d'exister à partir du
moment où quelqu'un veut se lancer dans
un élevage puis il y a pas accès au
service d'un vétérinaire
ça peut pas fonctionner depuis monsieur
pentasullia au besoin un vétérinaire
d'une autre région il s'est aussi doté
d'une pharmacie
super pharmacie mettez avant de ne pas
prendre
il était ici dans quelques heures puis
amenaient les produits qu'on avait
besoin maintenant mais ça nous prend les
produits pour être capable de se
débrouiller
[Musique]
autre mesure adoptées par Valéria Wilson
pour pallier au départ de ses collègues
la diminution des gardes les soirs et
les fin de semaine hey salut salut ça va
[Musique]
commencer les moyens du bord l'animal
vie ou ça dépend du problème
[Musique]
si on n'a pas de vétérinaire c'est
surtout parce que souvent c'est les
médicaments qui nous manque à ce
moment-là on peut rien faire
[Musique]
ici mais c'est plus rien c'est de donner
une petite chance puis on va avec ça
mais tu es présentement pour la pâte
tout à l'heure revenu dans l'ordre de
[Musique]
mais je trouve vraiment que c'est
ganglions sont augmentés de volume par
exemple Valérie après 4 heures à
travailler plus c'est à côté là qui est
plutôt difficile
comme le jour notre nouvel âge que on a
dû appeler un 26 décembre le monsieur il
s'est déplacé pour venir ici pour
défaire la torsion que la vache avait
ça aurait pu avoir un vétérinaire plus
proche
ça aurait été moins difficile pour tout
le monde
[Musique]
certains clients comme l'éleveur de
cette ferme ovine relativise les choses
on peut pas nous demander d'être là 365
jours année 24 heures par jour quand on
sait que sur le côté humain on a de la
misère avoir un médecin moi et pas de
médecin depuis 4 ans quand j'ai eu
besoin de médecins une fois j'ai trouvé
d'aller à Saint-Jovite que je peux pas
en demander plus à elle
[Musique]
moi je pense que les vétérinaires au
Québec même si on a des ruptures je
pense encore plus vite c'est une urgence
après midi mettons là je vais appeler
Valérie une heure une heure et demie
après peut-être là si je vais à
l'urgence à l'hôpital ça va peut-être
prendre 10 heures 12 heures
[Musique]
cette année-là Valérie
[Applaudissements]
depuis deux semaines je vais trouver
dans le parc sur le côté mais fais pas
de fièvre il y a pas l'intérêt mange
bien mais on voit que son train arrière
fonctionne pas bien là
on voit quelque chose au niveau nerveux
c'est bilatéral les deux barres puis la
queue qui est molle aucun tonus ça se
peut qu'il y ait une petite une petite
atteinte nerveuse au niveau de la
colonne on est en région éloignée on
peut pas demander plus le mou je pense
qu'il faut juste s'ajuster puis trouver
des solutions ensemble puis à date ça va
bien mais c'est sûr qu'il peut arriver
un cas majeur un samedi ou un dimanche
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver mais à
date tu fais du bois pas trop de
problèmes avec ça
[Musique]
énormément de route puis que tu as vite
que dans ta journée puis c'est très bien
que ça c'est juste impossible avec la
route que tu as à faire mais s'il y a
certains cas qu'on est capable de gérer
par téléphone ou par zoom ou par
autrement que de se déplacer sur le cas
tant mieux
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez fréquemment dû
gérer ça des interventions par téléphone
avec des clients oui c'est moi qui a
pris la pièce c'était une vache qui
était en prolapsus souterrain c'est une
vache que quand qu'elle mette l'enfant
son utérus sort au complet puis le
client était pris avec ça donc j'ai
conseillé du mieux que je pouvais le
client au téléphone de comment
laver ça mettre ça tranquillement dans
la vache puis c'est d'essayer de
le faire par lui-même puis au fait cette
vache là survécu puis le client a réussi
ça se passe pas toujours comme ça mais
tu sais quand t'as pas le choix comme
pas le choix il y en a pas d'autres
vétérinaires
tant que tu en fais pas pareil comme ça
[Musique]
pour atténuer la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre le ministère de l'Agriculture
du Québec forme désormais les éleveurs
pour qu'ils puissent poser des gestes
qui étaient autrefois la chasse gardée
des vétérinaires à vue d'impuissance du
système ou initiative constructive pour
tous ceux qui sont concernés l'important
c'est d'abord d'assurer la santé des
bêtes
[Musique]
Sylvain Charbonneau est l'un des plus
importants producteurs laitiers de la
région
même si Valérie Harrison et sa
vétérinaire attitré un autre
professionnel lui rend parfois visiteurs
[Musique]
moi je suis vétérinaire à la Clinique
Vétérinaire de Saint-Alexis on est situé
dans l'anaudière on est une équipe de 11
vétérinaires il y a deux ans quand
Valérie a perdu son sa partenaire comme
vétérinaire on a commencé à envoyer des
vétérinaires les mercredis et jeudi ici
à toutes les semaines pour donner un
coup de main et faire les formations et
aussi on va remplacer là les vacances là
de Valérie avant quelqu'un qui va tirer
avec la corde de balle autant ça un peu
la tête puis l'autre avec sa main à
l'intérieur au menu aujourd'hui
manipulation
utérine en cas de vêlage difficile
de l'autre côté vraiment là tu sens par
exemple pour former toute l'équipe du
producteur laitier Julien Pierre huppé
reçoit une prime du ministère de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation du
Québec le matin le but offrir des
services dans les régions où il y a une
pénurie de vétérinaire
[Musique]
ton col qui a pas dilaté ce cours est
donné dans le cadre d'un projet pilote
et laboré pour la région des Laurentides
on veut idéalement que les gens soient
capables de régler une bonne partie des
urgences vétérinaire par eux-mêmes donc
c'est de s'habituer tranquillement pas
vite à faire ça et aussi de tenir une
pharmacie en conséquence parce que dans
le cas d'une mamie aiguë
des injections intraveineuses et une
utilisation d'antibiotiques il faut que
dans la pharmacie de Monsieur ça soit
disponible parce que c'est pas en
quelque sorte on a vu d'impuissance du
système
non moi je vois plus
si le producteur est capable lui-même de
régler une situation rapidement et que
une heure plus tard le corps est réglé
comme dans le cas d'une torsion utérine
ben l'animal a été traité plus
rapidement
il y a pas eu de frais qui étaient
reliés à ça et puis on a un animal mieux
plus vite sans avoir eu besoin là de
paquet d'intervenants
Charbonneau a beau être compréhensif il
est en désaccord avec la nouvelle
approche du MAPA
Q si on veut remonter en production
notre région on veut pas la fermer mais
moi je trouve que c'est pas principe qui
valorisant pour nous mais ça décourage
la relève qui s'en vient puis ça
décourage peut-être même des personnes
qui veulent même s'installer en
agriculture dans notre région
ça apporte une mauvaise image
[Musique]
je me dis écoute je sais pas comment que
nous autorités
c'est pas logique
je pense que c'est c'est pas
envisageable d'avoir plus de
vétérinaires qui vont être disponibles
dans le secteur bialimentaire à court
terme on a des primes d'attraction pour
les vétérinaires qui vont pratiquer dans
des régions qu'on considère comme étant
fragile
on a des prix aussi pour la relève donc
des étudiants qui décident de s'orienter
dans le secteur bio-alimentaire vont
recevoir une prime aussi dans les
premières années de pratique donc je
pense que c'est très porteur en ce
moment pour
je dirais maintenir comme je l'ai éteint
les feux
en proxylvain Charbonneau et
sa fille ils ont acheté tout un attirail
médical
je pense si rien que se passe c'est ça
veut dire qu'elle fait pas
[Musique]
ça fait au moins 20 ans que la pénurie
de vétérinaire se fait sentir les locaux
de l'école la Faculté de Médecine
Vétérinaire de Saint-Hyacinthe sont trop
petits pour accueillir et former plus de
96 étudiants par année
sans compter que les jeunes recrues se
tournent majoritairement par la pratique
des animaux de compagnie
pour tenter d'inverser la tendance 15
places sont maintenant réservées aux
étudiantes première année qui acceptent
de faire des stages d'observation sur
une ferme Nicolas Mathieu on a fait
l'expérience l'été dernier j'ai appris
beaucoup comment travailler avec des
animaux comment surtout les manipuler
des bovins de boucheries c'est plus
dangereux un petit peu sont beaucoup
moins habitués au contact humain ça me
permet de développer un certain niveau
de contact et d'expérience avec ces
animaux là jusqu'à présent l'initiative
semble porter fruit j'ai un professeur
dans le domaine des bovins et puis
qu'enseignent puis un moment donné il
m'envoie un petit courriel en disant
Marie j'ai enseigné au premier année
cette année je leur ai demandé de lever
la main ceux qui s'en vont dans les
bovins puis j'ai eu une vingtaine de
mains qui sont levés puis j'ai failli
verser une larme
aussi permis de connaître différentes
manières de penser manières de gérer une
ferme des producteurs puis en voyant
tout ce beau monde là devant moi je
savais que je voulais aller en médecine
l'été prochain Nicolas Mathieu
consolidera son intérêt avec un
véritable stage sur une ferme payée par
le Mac l'objectif c'est vraiment une
exposition précoce à la pratique
vétérinaire en milieu agricole dès les
premières années du cursus en médecine
vétérinaire
jusqu'à présent qu'est-ce que ça donne
comme résultat des bons résultats
jusqu'à maintenant ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'au dessus de 60% des étudiants qui
graduent et qui s'orientent dans le
secteur bio-alimentaire on fait des
stages
[Musique]
de préparation des regards
j'ai acheté une maison
où ils ont logé parce que la place pour
des stagiaires entre temps les cliniques
vétérinaires font tout pour recruter les
étudiants de 4e et 5e année en médecine
vétérinaire avant leur graduation
faites quoi chirurgien
[Musique]
orthopédique
complet on a avec le suivi tout ça radio
dentaire la dentisterie on en fait ça
fait longtemps si on a tout le temps
lors de cette soirée de réseautage
Express les cliniques des régions
éloignées comme celle du Thémis scamang
avait 7 minutes pour vendre leurs
candidature
présentement on avait parti à la
retraite cet automne donc là on est en
pénurie franche de vétérinaire donc
c'est important qu'on qu'on réussisse à
compléter compléter notre équipe et
pourquoi c'est difficile de recruter
est-ce que c'est parce que vous êtes au
médicament parce que oui c'est une
région qui est méconnue beaucoup
beaucoup la bitibi s'en sort un peu
mieux c'est une région qui est plus
connue médicalement il est moins mais
chaque clinique a son challenge là pour
recruter des vétérinaires c'est
difficile
est-ce que tu penses y aller en stage et
c'est sûr que ça serait dans mes
possibilités là j'ai pris l'Antiquité
pour avoir leur courriel et mais
éventuellement le oui c'est vraiment une
place qui m'intéresse qui est ressorti
du Lot aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les soirées de réseautage elle met sur
autre chose pour recruter
je pense qu'avec les stages du MAPAQ ça
va vraiment aider il y a des jeunes
stagiaires qui est venu avec moi l'année
passée qui veut revenir cette année qui
est super intéressé à la région fait que
je pense que ça c'est ça aide plus tu as
plus le contact avec la personne qui a
pu vraiment voir ce que tu fais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous diriez à des jeunes
finissant là pour essayer de leur faire
la grande séduction puis de les amener
ici
premièrement
la diversité d'espèces c'est vraiment
vraiment enrichissant c'est super le fun
de travailler avec plein de sortes
d'animaux différents
les gens en région sont beaucoup plus
relaxes et zen que les gens des grands
centres honnêtement j'ai des clients en
or c'est une super belle région les gens
qui aiment le plein air tu as pas besoin
que tu te déplacer pour faire du plein
air noter déjà dedans avec les gens qui
triplent qui aiment faire de la montagne
la raquette de ce qui te font de la
pêche de la chasse si c'est vraiment une
région pour ceux aussi donc je pense que
c'est un tout
[Musique]